let's say that I'm a pension fund and I
have money to lend to other people and I
want to lend it to other people because
it that way I can get interest on it
instead of it just kind of sitting and
doing nothing and if I lend it to
someone other than the government I'll
get better interest so let's say that
there's so let me let me draw me I'm the
pension fund maybe I'll draw me in
magenta so that's me pension fund
pension fund pension fund and let's say
that there's some corporation I don't
know let's say it's GM they make cars I
think you've heard of them some
corporation GM but let's just call them
Corporation a corporation a they need to
borrow money maybe to buy a factory or
to do something else we're not going to
get involved in what they need the money
for and I'd like to lend them the money
but there is an issue there's an issue
here I'm a pension fund I manage I don't
know I manage the retirement fund for
the teachers of California or for the
Auto Workers of Michigan or whatever and
part of my Charter says that I can only
invest in very very very safe
instruments so I'm not allowed to go
gamble people's money because this is
you know this is people's retirement so
I can't do very fancy things with it so
I can only invest in things that are
rated triple-a or let's say double-a I'm
just kind of making this up on the fly
so triple-a would be like the highest
rated securities right these are things
that have a very low chance of default
but corporation a is only rated I don't
know triple let's say it's rated BB and
actually this is a good time to think
about well who's doing all of these
ratings and you might think oh it surely
is a government entity because only the
government would be objective enough to
give all of these corporations frankly
objective ratings but unfortunately it's
not
they're private entities the private
entities that are actually paid to rate
things and I think I touched it touched
on it in the video on collateralized
debt obligations but their incentives
are a little bit strange but let's say I
have Moody's Moody's is one of the
ratings agencies
and they rate corporation a as BB so
they've said no you know these guys
they're pretty good but you know they're
not like the US government or something
there's a there's a chance that they can
go under for whatever reasons or that
you know they're they're sensitive to
the economy as a whole and I say man you
know I would love to lend these guys
money
I would love to lend these guys the I
don't know the billion dollars that they
need and these guys are willing to pay
me eight percent interest but I can't do
it me as a pension fund I cannot lend
the money because I'm only allowed to
lend money to I don't know single a or
above types of bonds or you know I can
only buy single a or above type of
instruments so what do I do i this guy
needs money I have money to give him but
he's his he's kind of corporate credit
rating that was given by Moody's just
isn't high enough for me to lend him the
money and this is where credit default
swaps come in so in an ideal world I
would give corporation a I would give
them a billion dollars and then maybe
they would annually give me I don't know
let me make up a number ten percent ten
percent per year and then this might
have a term for ten years and after ten
years they'll pay me the billion dollars
back and then I'll be happy but as I
said multiple times I can't do it
because they are BB rated and my Charter
says I can only invest in a rated bonds
so I go to another entity and let's
let's call this entity AIG and these
entities are essentially insurance
companies on debt and I'm calling this
one AIG because AIG was actually did do
this but it could be anything a lot of
banks did this a lot of insurance
companies did this there were some
companies that just specialized in
writing collateralized sorry in writing
credit default swaps baby what does AIG
do for me well first of all it's
important to note that
Moody's has given AIG I don't know let's
give it a double A rating I don't know
what their actual rating was they said
you know what
they are almost risk-free they're almost
like the US government Moody's has
looked at their books or supposedly or
hopefully has looked at their books and
says well you know they're there if you
loan them money they're good for it so
they have a very very high rating
although once again you have to worry
about the incentive because who paid
Moody's to give them that rating and
whenever there's you know you're getting
paid to give a rating you have to wonder
about what your incentives are in terms
of how you rate things but anyway that's
that's that's a discussion for another
video but what AIG says is you know what
pension fund I know you want to lend
corporation a money and corporation a
wants to borrow money from you but you
have this problem because they're double
berated so we're going to do is we're
going to ensure we're going to ensure
this bond we're going to ensure this
loan that you're giving to corporate B
so what we just want in return for that
is an insurance premium we want you to
pay us a little bit of this interest
every year if you pay us a little bit of
this interest every year we will insure
this payment so you get 10% a year and I
don't know you give us 1% a year
so you give us 1% a year so 1% a year 1%
a year and this is also 1 percent just
in just to learn a little bit of
financial jargon this is also you know
someone would say 100 basis points a
basis points is one one basis point is
one hundredth of a percent so one
percent is the same thing as 100 basis
points 2 percent is the same thing as
200 basis points so you pay me a hundred
basis points of the 10 percent per year
and in exchange I will give you
insurance
I'll give you insurance insurance on on
A's debt and in fact it might have not
even been structured this way it might
have been structured so that corporation
a right here before even issuing the
bonds they include this insurance with
the bonds so instead of taking 10
percent instead of giving 10 percent
they cut out 1 percent to insure it and
then these essentially become triple
Double A bonds and why is that well this
is their double B but you're being
insured by someone
is double-a so all of a sudden these
bonds because they're being insured by
this entity that is double aid which
Moody's has you know determined is
double-a these bonds are now good enough
for my pension fund to hold because I
say you know what even if corporation a
goes under I have this double a guy
insuring it and so I'm fine so this is
the equivalent of holding double-a bonds
and what's my effective interest rate
well I'm getting nine percent per year
right I'm getting 10 percent per year
from corporation B and then I have to
pay 1% to AIG and if corporation B goes
under tomorrow
AIG is going to give me my billion
dollars back and you might say hey Sal
this sounds like a like a pretty good
situation and and and and this is where
it starts to get a little bit shady
because AIG they're not just insuring my
my debt or my my loan that I gave to
corporation a and think about it AIG
didn't have to do anything and you
didn't have to put up any collateral AIG
didn't say didn't say oh you know what
out of all of our assets here is here is
a billion dollars that we're going to
set aside just in case corporation a
doesn't pay right you would think that
if you wanted to be guaranteed that this
money was going to come to you this AIG
corporation would have to set aside the
money but they didn't have to do that
they just had to say hey
Moody's has said we're Double A we're
good for debt we're good for insurance
so you just pay us 1% a year and trust
us or trust Moody's that we really are
good for the money they never had to set
aside the money so you're just kind of
going on built on a leap of faith that
if and when corporation a defaults AIG
is going to be good for the money now
this is where it gets interesting let me
let me erase Moody's from the screen
actually maybe I'll I'll do it I'll go
down here
AIG didn't just insure my debt let's say
that there is Corporation C's debt
Corporation C Corporation C let's say
that there be I don't know they're all
these ratings have different
terminologies you'll see their b plus
rated right and let's say there's 10
billion dollars of
at that they borrow from some other
party ten billion and then then return I
don't know they give eleven percent and
this is I don't know this is pension
fund B pension fund B and these this
pension fund had the same problem they
can only buy a rated or above bonds so
AIG also insures their their debt that
they gave to corporation C so maybe
they'll pay them corporation C is maybe
a little bit riskier so out of the
eleven percent I have to pay maybe I
don't know 150 basis points or
one-and-a-half percent that's the same
thing as one percent and in exchange
they insure insure C's debt now
something very interesting can happen
here AIG all of a sudden has an
excellent business model right because
they were able to get this double A
rating from Moody's they can just keep
insuring other people's debt and they
don't have to put any money aside right
they don't have to they don't have to
set give this their their assets to
anyone else and they just get these
income streams right from from my
pension fund they're getting 1% per year
of the billion dollars from this pension
fund they're getting one and a half
percent one hundred fifty basis points
per year and they could do this frankly
as much as they want they could do this
a thousand times and as long as Moody's
doesn't get suspicious as long as
Moody's say doesn't start saying hey
wait wait wait a second
AIG you only have a hundred billion
dollars in assets but you have insured a
trillion dollars of other people's debt
something shady going on I'm going to
lower your rating as long as that
doesn't happen this AIG corporation can
just keep insuring more and more debt
and frankly as long as none of that debt
goes bad they just get this excellent
income stream and their CEO will get
excellent bonuses anyway I think you
start to see where you're having a
single point of failure in a kind of a
house of cards and I'll continue that in
the next video